[Music]  you know I think I probably spent most  of my entire life looking in the mirror  Jack Nicholson Quinn Eastwood I came  here when I was 17 on a bus basically  and and got up at the Comedy Store in  the original room and kind of tripped  over the microphone and stuff like that  I was very nervous  it's a beautiful day Petey the  extra-terrestrial  [Music]  [Applause]  well for me this kind of felt like the  big-time to me it was like this is the  place where you saw Robin Williams and  you saw people like that just trying out  stuff and bomb and then stuff like that  not very often Robin but occasionally  something wouldn't work and now Wiley  coyote walking away from a bad fall like  a Saturday night you come to point your  best stuff but then sometimes it's 2:00  in the morning on a Tuesday night and  you just go you know my act doesn't  matter anymore and and that's when you  really grow you you find stuff that you  would never have found at 8 o'clock on  Saturday night